We've finally gotten our first official look
at Nintendo's ninth-generation console, the
Switch.
Details were light in the days after the its
official announcement.
But based on first impressions, it sure seems
like the new system could be capable of going
head to head with the Xbox One and the PlayStation
4.
Here's a rundown on what we know about the
Nintendo Switch so far, and how it will stack
up against the competition.
It's a console...and a portable!
By now, you may be wondering why Nintendo
called its new console the Switch.
Well check THIS out!
"That's crazy!"
That's right, with this new console, gamers
will be able to SWITCH from playing at home
or on the go.
The trailer shows more scenarios, like playing
on a park bench, on an airplane, and even
on the road.
And when you've gotten where you're going?
Just plug that thing back into the TV.
From what we can see in the trailer, the Switch
seems nowhere near as bulky as the Wii U gamepad.
Instead, Nintendo's latest console has a sleek
and slim design that's more reminiscent of
a tablet.
Ever since 1989, Nintendo has dominated the
handheld gaming market.
Microsoft never really did much with its tablet-based
SmartGlass project.
And Sony's portable ambitions with the PSP
and PlayStation Vita couldn't ever touch Nintendo.
If the Switch is can truly deliver on the
promise of being a fully functional home-portable
hybrid, Nintendo will give Microsoft and Sony
a run for their money.
The mighty Joy-Con
The Switch's detachable controllers, called
Joy-Cons, will give players tons of options.
The two little doohickeys can be attached
to one controller hub, the Switch console
itself, can be used like Wii-style nunchucks,
or even as individual controllers for multiple
players.
That's four different configurations for one
device.
And then there's also the "Nintendo Switch
Pro Controller" that made an appearance in
the trailer.
While Sony and Microsoft both offer traditional-style
wireless controllers for their consoles, they
have nothing like the Joy-Con's adaptability.
Mobile multiplayer
Nintendo wants to bring back local multiplayer
in a big way.
The trailer shows more than one Switch console
being linked together, apparently wirelessly.
It seems like a fair bet that the Switch will
have some form of Wi-Fi built in, too.
But until Nintendo tells us more, we're only
guessing.
The Switch also looks like it's built with
eSports in mind, with two teams of gamers
getting together to duke it out over a game
of Splatoon.
Kick it with the stand
Back in the GameCube days, Nintendo decided
to stick a little handle on their flagship
console, so you could carry it around like
a lunchbox...which cost two-hundred dollars.
This time around, however, the Switch looks
like it's truly equipped for gameplay anywhere,
anytime.
Why?
It's got a kickstand!
This may not seem important, but small details
like this can make or break a device.
If you're tired of holding the whole console,
you can set it up on a table and get comfortable.
As far as design decisions go, that tiny piece
of plastic is actually kind of brilliant.
Putting the cart before the disc
The rumors are true: Nintendo is ditching
discs in favor of cartridges.
The Switch seems to run on small game cards,
apparently similar in size and shape to 3DS
game cards.
Unfortunately, Nintendo confirmed that the
Switch won't play Wii U discs or 3DS game
cartridges.
Still, it's possible the Switch might rely
on SD cards — just like the 3DS — for
expandable internal storage, meaning players
might be able to carry lots of games on each
card.
Either way, that means lots of games on the
go.
Nvidia visuals
On the same day that Nintendo's Switch trailer
went live, Nvidia announced that it had provided
the console with a custom Tegra processor,
"based on the same architecture as the world's
top-performing GeForce gaming graphics cards."
Of course, a console's performance can't be
summed up by knowing just one of the components
that's under the hood.
And as of the making of this video, Nintendo
hasn't revealed any of the Switch's internal
hardware specs.
However, the trailer gives us a glimpse at
someone playing a game that sure does look
like Skyrim, both on the go and on the television.
An article on Ars Technica speculates that
the Switch will switch between 720p and 1080p
visuals depending on whether it's on the go
or in the dock.
We won't know how close it'll stack up to
the PlayStation 4 or Xbox One until we know
more about its internal specs, but it seems
safe to say that it won't look like, well,
this.
"Hello!"
New exclusives and a third-party party
For years, Nintendo has struggled to attract
third-party gamemakers to make software for
its consoles.
It's obviously way too early to know whether
or not the Switch will remedy that problem
in the long run.
But Nintendo revealed that nearly 50 third-party
publishers and developers have committed to
their new console.
We know the Switch will have new games featuring
Super Mario, The Legend of Zelda, and Mario
Kart.
But having top-tier, triple-A games from the
likes of Bethesda, EA, and Capcom?
That could help the Switch get hardcore gamers
on board, while also appealing to lifelong
Nintendo fans and casual gamers alike.
Waiting to flip the Switch
For all that we know — or think we know
— there's still plenty we don't.
As of the making of this video, we're still
in the dark about the Switch's full tech specs,
its launch titles, its actual release date,
or even the console's purchase price.
How long will the batteries last?
How much will it cost to replace a JoyCon
after one of them gets thrown out the window
during a vigorous session of minivan Mario
Kart?
Because that's totally going to happen.
But even with the little information we do
have, it seems like Nintendo wants the Switch
to make waves.
Could this be the console Nintendo meant to
make when the Wii U flopped?
Will it capture the attention and hard earned
cash of casual and hardcore game fans alike?
"Shut up and take my money!"
Only time will tell.
But one thing's for sure: we've never seen
a console like this before.
In the end, there's only one thing we can
say to Nintendo about the Switch:
"Good luck!"
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know what
you think about the Nintendo Switch...